So you know that thing where
you move house, but imagine you
forgot to tell your friends.
And then they come round for
dinner, and they're like,
did you still want
us round for dinner?
And you're like, yeah.
I've just realized
I've moved house,
and I forgot to tell you.
And that's awkward.
Well, that's exactly
what's happened, folks.
You're watching this on the
Google Developers Channel,
but all the web content has now
moved to the Chrome Developers
Channel.
Shazam.
So you can find this
show, "Supercharged,"
where I take people's sites and
try and find performance fixes.
You can find "Polycasts"
with Rob Dodson.
You can find "Totally Tooling
Tips" with Matt Gaunt and Addy
Osmani.
And you can find
"HTTP 203" with me
and Jake Archibald,
all over there, all
packaged up nice and neatly.
So head over there.
Subscribe.
And I guess I'll see you there.
Bye.